it is game night you ready for this I  got a new laptop Sooey you there's a  cyber cafe that I've been working out  and this computer was sitting in the  lost and found for the last three or  four weeks  hang on he stole someone's computer it  stood up I found this folder it was  hidden and it automatically connects you  to this thing  dude this is dark web or dark web  probably the Internet where no one can  track you solve out drugs illegal IDs  seem an assassination for hi-yah the  dark nut it's mostly about the bad guys  and just computer it's got videos on the  right check this out I really think you  should stop guys that's what they're  trading videos  we have to do something  is that big guys hold up where's Lex the  ones you buy the videos the ones you  pick the girls please leave us alone  I can hear you are you tell me I can't  see you  you